okay let's start
okay welcome to the ddps seminar today
before we introduce our invited speaker
today
uh let's go over some rules and
logistics
as usual first of all please mute
yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you're welcome to admit
yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please use chat room
to post your questions so that we can
address them in
q a session at the end second
no classified discussion is allowed so
please
watch out finally the talk today will be
recorded and
uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it now let me introduce our
speaker today
it is an honor to host today's speaker
treyang who is a professor in the
department
of mathematics at virginia tech
he won the siam student paper
prize in 1999 received his ph.d
phd in 2000 from the university of
pittsburgh and was
a 2000 2001 wilkins fellow at argon
national lab
and joined virginia tech in 2002
his research focuses around
the numerical simulation and analysis of
turbulent engineering and geophysical
flows
with a special emphasis on reduced
modeling
today professor um treyan
will present large eddy simulation
reduced auto models
so-called less roms which will be very
interesting topic
so enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
from
treyan today now without further ado let
me pass the button to
uh professor treyan
thank you thank you sir so that was a
super nice introduction thank you for
for inviting me giving me this chance
i'm i'm really uh happy to to to be here
db stock
um i will talk about uh largely
simulation when you store the models
um please feel free to interrupt me um
uh you can wait until the end
obviously but as young sue said so
you can stop and you know um ask
admit yourself and ask a question i'll
be glad to to to answer your question
okay
so um um here's what i want to do i want
to
to emphasize the goal of this talk
really so
i would like to give an overview of what
we've been doing in our group for the
past decade or so i'm an old guy
as you can see from the uh presentation
and in particular
really so our one of our main thrusts
has been on uh connecting two distinct
research fields
uh there's larger the simulation leds
this is a classical
field in the numerical simulation of
terminal flows you know this
uh it also reduced all the modeling this
is a newer field
and i think that there is a uh a very
good connection between the two and i
will try to argue
that this is a good idea okay
the main goal is to enable reduced or
the modeling
of turbulent flows okay so this is the
main goal of
what we're trying to do and lds an elias
philosophy uh so they represent the
vehicles
of our uh approach okay
i have two sales pitch uh the first one
is actually the important one and what
what i want to emphasize in my talk
is the principles used in developing our
models and i will uh answer
mainly two questions one is why
so why are we doing this why why are we
trying to connect alias and distorted
modeling
and other people as well of course i'll
try to overview the uh their work as
well
but also how how exactly do we do this
there are two distinct fields how
exactly do you put them together
all right what the focus
so the focus is on principles the focus
is not really on models
um but i have to admit that of course i
have
i'm selling models so i would be very
glad if you
if you were interested in our models if
you wanted to to work with them
collaborate with us
and see how to take them uh further down
the road okay
all right so uh this is the outline of
my talk it has
three distinct parts the first one is
classical
it's larger this simulation so i will
show you
some of the results that we we obtained
the
in a wonderful collaboration um
about 10 years ago and then i will move
on to
larger the simulation runs so this is
the framework
that we're using in developing our
models
it's the second part of my talk so this
is not standard
the third part is about the specific
model
really and this is a data-driven
variation multi-scale rom this is the
model we've been using
in our group for the past couple of
years okay
now we'll end up with some conclusions
and uh
and future word type of directions
okay so once again three parts i'll go
through this relatively quickly that's
not the focus this is mainly for
background
alias i know most of you know
lds but just to make sure we're on the
same page
okay so as i said this is surveying a
lot of work
uh the the this work mainly has been
done with my students
and my postdocs the two of them chiang
hong
is moving to wisconsin to work in uh
manchester group
and the guild is going to spain to the
university of sydney to work with
thomas jacquez group
and you have here so some of my former
students
and former postdocs but also
collaborators
and for example like the last part of my
talk is uh
done pretty much in uh collaboration
with leo my academic brother leo reports
but a lot of it has has been done with
with the others
and the first part of my talk the one
the older one on lds
has been done with paul fisher uh
tamara's bookman and
oceanographer and jeffrey dwan and apply
mathematician okay
so let me start with lds and i will
present this application that
we we used we focused a while ago
this is on um the thermal hairline
circulation
now you must have seen this type of
schematics
um depicting the
ocean large scale ocean circulation
we have warm masses of water at the
surface
cold masses of water at the so deep down
and if you i think the schematic on the
right
really depicts what's going on the
process itself
so if you take the north atlantic the
atlantic ocean and you go
take a cross section what you will see
is something that uh looks like this
right so you have
the the pole you have cold weather
uh cold masses of water going down the
continent that
you know down the slope mixing with the
ambient one
water okay getting to the equator
warming up then the cycle repeats goes
back the worm
the warm water goes back to the north
pole and the cycle repeats itself it's a
long cycle
it's like years decades you know you
know
thousands of years i don't know hundreds
of years okay but this is the process
and our goal was to try to simulate the
mixing
in in the ocean we thought a little bit
about
it and we realized that this is actually
uh not so easy
and they said let's focus on a small
scale
type of application and the small scale
application that we focused on was the
red sea overflow
okay so the overflow overflow in the red
sea
this is a small scale by geophysical
abortion
modeling standards a small scale type of
process the domain was 10 kilometers
long
and the kilometer in height and in width
so these these were the scales
there was also experimental data
of the observational data to compare
with and we tried we thought
how do we simulate this type of overflow
since we have experimental data
and the back of the envelope calculation
showed us that if we were to simulate
all the scales in this small scale type
of process
we using you know
standard uh specific type of uh
characteristic of velocity scales and
length scales
we get with the number of degrees of
freedom that's like 10 to the 18th
and we thought that we should not do
that
and instead what we should do is just
use a
coarse mesh that is you know that is
uh approachable with our computational
uh available computational power
and thus we admitted that we will be
working
in an under-resolved regime now come
back to this
so basically we admitted from the very
beginning that we're going to work with
a course mesh
and then we have to use something to
make up for that with this on the result
regime
at least something is lds that's what we
chose
okay now so what is lds and i i
apologize for those of you have seen
this i've taken this in
graduate school uh but i just wanted to
make sure that we're on the same page
so this is a very general technique okay
turbulent flows right numerical
simulation
the idea is very clear well it's a crash
course one slide crash course in lds so
you have you can think of your flow
field as a signal in 1d
let's say that has both large scale
and small scale components so low wave
number and high wave number components
right so this is you right here in
maroon
however you also know that your mesh is
very coarse
this is your numerical mesh so the
question is how do you approximate
this signal you on such a coarse mesh
the alias idea is very general and it's
very simple
it basically says that you take your
signal u
and you filter it with a spatial filter
and this is the orange signal the smooth
one
now u-bar this filter signal
will not have the high wave number
components obviously
so you lose something but it will
preserve
the large scale component the low wave
number component
and this can be represented onto your
course numerical mesh
so that's the idea inaudible right in
less so instead of solving all
you know you you solve for you the
filtered variables
now in terms of filters and many filters
in lds but
yeah so you can do this in the physical
space you can use something like the
gaussian filter
we can do this in the fourier space yeah
you use something like the sharp cut off
filter
okay there are many other filters yeah
um okay and then the process is simple
again do not solve for the variables
themselves
solve for the filter variables u bar is
equal to
filter d i use this convolution operator
but
really this means the filter variable
they represent the large scales
this u bar right here the smooth curve
now we don't have equations for the
filter variables we only have equations
for the
original variable so what do we do we
take the equations and navier-stokes
equations and we filter them
yeah and then we solve for the filter
variables
simple this is it this is the idea lds
in one slide of course it's much more
complicated than this
and what happens is actually that when
you filter nonlinear equations you're
gonna get the closure term i wrote it
in this form right here and this is
again
due to the non-linear uh so this should
be d u dt
uh this is uh this uh i actually this is
quite sorry
so this is this is written in this uh in
this form it's the non-linear term that
that you have to model
that's the closure term yeah okay
there are different types of closure
models uh
so i would say using piers ago's
technology that the most popular
type of models are the physical models
these are called
functional models they're physical think
of very viscosity models
moles that dissipate energy or
smaller class structural models
different types of structural models as
well these are mathematical
think of asymptotics series expansions
things like this okay all right
okay we use both in our investigation
and this is the
these are the numerical results i'll go
to try to go through this uh
quickly emphasizing the issues okay so
we chose our computational domain this
is the computational domain
and as a test problem we chose an
academic test problem
the damn break problem what is this so
in this rectangular domain you have cold
water to the left
warm water to the right and then you
have a
a wall separating them this is right
here this is the wall
it has a disturbance so that you start
things quickly
at time t equals zero you pull out the
wall
so you see what happens with the cold
and warm
uh masses of water so what's gonna
happen is that they're gonna slosh
around
you know go back and forth in the
process
they're gonna mix and the mixing is
denoted in green here
blue represents warm water red
represents cold water
i used to have a movie but it would
crash my presentation
so anything for that okay you can see it
here after one thing stabilize
and the question was can we simulate
this with our les models
can we simulate this mixing with our
alias marks
then we said okay if we are to do this
we have to use a coarse mesh
all right because that's the realistic
case and that's what we did here
okay so i'll go back and forth to kind
of get an idea about coarse mesh fine
mesh so fine mesh
this hexahedron so we will use paul
fischer's
spectral element code so in each uh
break we have like
six you know polynomials of degree 16
17 things like so it's a lot of mesh
points
but look at this much closer
so we correspond significantly recursive
dimensional directions
and look what happens with the features
so here you see very small features
yeah so you have a fine mesh to capture
everything in the flow
in here you don't have those everything
is smoothed out
and it's fine as long as you're
interested in a bulk type of
approximation that should be good yeah
okay so we used different lds models
we fixed the accuracy when we tested our
models lowering
numbers and we obtained a significant
speed up by earlier standards this is
really good we're lucky
because we're looking at mixing up you
know other quantities right
so it's very good okay all right
now this last picture that i want to
show you
is this is it in my opinion is like the
it's the one i like the most because it
really shows how
leds should be used so we calibrated our
alias models
for lower this number thirty thousand
and this is the solid line right here
and then for the high realms number
one million for which we could not do
dns
with our available resources we just ran
an ensemble of lds models we took the
average
and we predicted the green line
this average as the the amount of mixing
that will take place
at this higher number
okay so this was paper that appeared 12
years ago ocean modeling
um i i you know i think that this is
illustrates very well the principles of
lds
and i want you to start with this to
present
the main principles used in in less so
that's those are filtering
the idea that you have an under resolve
simulation
and that you do for the filter variables
on this course mesh
on the result simulation okay so
the first these are not mathematical
implications but realistic flows
under resolved we chose lds
different people might choose different
techniques yes
but lds is is an actual choice that's
the take-home message
okay i want to emphasize so this is a
shameless plug so
you can find literally hundreds
of lds models i'm not trying to sell you
an alias model
hundreds of these models in piers ago's
uh famous uh atlas
vs i checked that yesterday it has 4 000
citations it's very
it's very well known um
it's a the the field the largely
simulation is is is
settled everything is pretty clear their
developments of course but things are
pretty clear i also want to to to
note there's been mathematical
developments mathematical support for
these audience models
this is a book we wrote together with my
advisor my collaborator rich barcelli
thomas chakon uh lewandowski for crayon
so they've also written
mathematic books about mathematics of
larger dissimilation
all in all a pretty well settled field
okay well this is all about alias and
unless you have
questions so i'm gonna i want to move on
to uh
these are the modeling because this is
the main um
main focus of what we're doing okay
no questions i don't see anyone please
don't meet yourself and stop me
no problem okay
at the end fine okay now so about
reduced order modeling so this is a
completely different story
so reduced the modeling is not
especially for turbulence it's not uh
settled field
to say the least okay i will start with
the standard
uh type of automation so here we have a
um
time dependent uh pde very general form
and uh in one slide i'll try to explain
what
the galerkin projection based these were
the models do
it's an old idea uh basically you do a
an expansion in terms of
rom basis functions these are data
driven
so you obtain these basis functions vj
from data all right this is different
then you plug this approximation into
your equation and you project it
so the working projection onto the space
span
by your round basis functions so very
much in the speed i mean this is a good
working method
but with different basis functions data
driven
based on from data okay this is what you
get
and this is called the lurking raw so
you really
that used here dynamic resistant
notation you really have a
dynamical system yeah of dimension r
if you choose r small number of basis
functions
this is what you get at the end of the
day very simple
very straightforward this is just like
finite elements but instead of
have functions you use uh
basis functions that you choose from
data that's important actually
for donating so this is a for general
equation but for navier stokes
if you have incompressible flows so
that's what we're using
income stink water what you get is a dot
is equal to matrix capital a
times your vector of unknown
coefficients
and then you have a tensor b from the
nonlinear term
you pre-assemble this in the offline
phase
all right and then in the online phase
when you run you reduce or the model
you do a transpose vector transpose
tensor b times a and you get a vector
because b is a tensor
very straightforward very
straightforward does it work
yes it does okay but not
always and this is the slide that i
wanted to present
and i'm really i really want to i really
hope that you pay attention to this this
is the elephant in the room in the
reduced or the moderate community
one of the elephants in the room and
here i'm presenting
um a hierarchy of test problems
so really if you take this model this is
something that
you have hundreds on paper hundreds of
papers on these type of models
maybe your stokes incompressible navier
stokes models of this form
if you're interested in um in adding
pressure so
you know so uh for example uh john lee
rosa's group
has and reduce basis methods uh uh
community have done a lot of work about
that but
if not that's what you get okay standard
but when does it work and i think that
the answer
is problem dependent dependent test
dependent
for example this first problem
is flow two-dimensional flow past the
circular cylinder
this is the von karman vortex street
this is by far the workhorse
of reduced order modeling in fluid
dynamics
every conference you go to you will see
this type of problem
why because roms work awesome
in this case awesome right
you just kill it yeah with a simple
model awesome but what if you
push it a little bit so what if you for
example look at
the quasi-geostrophic equations start
you know represent the chaotic system
two-dimensional
but look quite a bit of interesting
motion here
huh and what happens if you push even
further
and here we have a standard
pest problem in turbulence academic test
problem in turbulence the medical
simulation of terminals
the turbulent channel flow this is i
will talk again about this this is
reynolds number 395 radon style
okay yeah okay
in this last picture we compare
the rate of decay of the eigenvalue
problem that you need to solve in order
to determine the
ground base pod base we're using pod
okay they give you a measure
of so the eigenvalues give you a measure
of the amount of energy
stored in each mode yes that these mode
represents
the faster the decay the easier it's
gonna be for you to simulate
with a reducer the model
look at this two-dimensional channel
flow
look how fast they decay yeah i mean if
you're here in the range of 10
r equals 10 i mean you're doing pretty
well
but look at the qge completely different
behavior
so they start to decay and then they
kind of plateau
so you within a lot of modes if you
wanted to simulate the whole
behavior the whole dynamics rom might
not be that good
even worse if you look at reynolds tau
395 channel flow simple three night
yeah i mean not a five on the style
yeah look at this look how much they
plateau
so what this tells you is that if you
have a reduced order model
that it should work pretty well in this
regime maybe not so well in these
regimes
and that's what we're gonna show next
okay
now take home message realistic flow
i believe that you also you're also in
this under-resolved regime
yeah so if you're here with a few modes
you're also not solving the whole
dynamics
so we're back to the problem from lds
yeah
okay so i'm saying the lds rom is not
an implication that's what we like but
some sort of extra work
yeah you need to do something on top of
the lurking wrong
okay this has been acknowledged in the
community so this is not in you
okay so what do you do i will present to
you the idea elias from idea
i have to uh solo movie okay
and really what we're doing we're
extending the alias ideas that i
presented before to the rom
setting simple here what we do
the first type of so we have to define a
filter
the first one is the easiest one
most of the time people use it but they
don't even call it a filter so
it's the wrong projection so if you have
a rom a variable that lives in a
large dimensional drum space so think of
capital r like
a thousand or 100
when you project that onto a smaller
dimensional rom subspace
or absolute subspace think of little r
as 10
so you go from 1000 to 10 or from 100 to
10.
of course you're gonna keep only the
large structures
so it does function like a filter
yeah similar in spirit with a um fourier
fatal filter in less what you do so this
is by far the most used type of approach
but you don't have to do this i mean you
can also think about using an actual
filter
physical filter we'll use this this
differential filter that i will talk in
a few slides
okay okay it's less popular far less
popular
and then the procedure is the same we
filter the variables
to determine the large scales we filter
the equations
and then we solve for the filter
variables at the end of the day
we get our alias rom
simple is the same type of dynamical
system the
lurking rom that we saw before plus
a correction term this is
in the spirit of lds we call this a
closure model
and this represents the interaction
between the modes the dynamics of the
modes that you keep in the system
and those that you get rid of by
by projection or filtering whatever
filtering you're using
projection let's say using projection
okay
that's it very nice simple exactly the
same thing
i'll come back to this spatial filter
because i think this is very important
yeah but
the projection i mean people don't even
mention this when they use it in
raw modeling yeah it's just the usual
coloring thing on a smaller space okay
you can not call it a filter if you
don't want but it's a filter yeah
okay now there are quite a few people
who have done this
and in this one slide i'm trying to
mention
some of the names i'm not gonna do
the you know justice to everyone and i
apologize for this
um i you know i would classify the the
current
uh closure models in reduced order
modeling
using the same earliest terminology as
functional
and functional means physical
eddy viscosity type of thing
and structural those are mathematical
i would also say that in each category
they're non-alias models and you have
you know starting burn and angelo
george kanye and dykus and charbel okay
so a long series of type of models of
this sort
but also alias models alias models are
functional type
the first one would be the pioneer
pioneer in the field
nominee but you can see like
more sophisticated type of lease models
along the way
we've done so we've done some of some of
this we were the first to introduce this
dynamic
subject model i think it's a pretty good
model i may also improve this
the same thing with structural modeling
you have non-alias type of approaches
different techniques so you know morris
wants egg
and you know vms and stochastic modeling
and lately machine learning and and all
okay but also aliens type of structural
modeling and this is something we've
done
and this is a model um that we developed
uh
four years ago and we'll talk about this
yeah so so
a plethora of models different
approaches some are lds some are not
data is starting to creep in and i'll
talk about this a little bit later on
okay so
no justice i cannot do this in one
slide but we're writing a paper so with
the mayor
omerson's group uh adil rasheed and uh
bernoullit
we we're serving some of these so
closure type of models and use closure
reduced order models i think this isn't
something that hasn't been done and
look out yeah so in a month or so we
hope that we can put it
on the market okay all right so we'll
try to do justice to everyone there all
right so
why are we using this type of closure
model well so here's my
sales pitch i think there are
similarities
between largety simulation and disorder
modeling and these similarities are not
always discussed
in so in the first place i think the
bases
are similar not the same but the
similarities
in fact if you read lumley's book
it shows that if you consider
homogeneous flow
how much in your system the pod basis is
identical to the fourier basis
when we've done this in our you know
numerical simulations and yes of course
you can prove that what does it of
course you shouldn't work with
homogeneous first for if you want to use
pod
i'm just saying that there is a
connection right
and this gives us confidence that maybe
we can use some of the ideas developed
in the earliest field
to extend them to produce or the model
right makes sense
and you've seen this type of of uh so
these are energy spectra
from from in that has nothing to do this
is the energy cascade based on common
goals
statistical theory of turbulence has
nothing to do with withdrawal
but in less in turbulence modeling so
you always see this type of uh
graphs for different reynolds numbers
for different reynolds numbers different
experiments right
you always pretty much get the same
minus five thirds so
that's the universal law this allows
while there's an energy cascade so the
low wave number
components just dissipate energy to
lower to high
wave number components and those in turn
dissipate
energy down the cascade until at the
very end
the common goal of scale they dissipate
in the form of
heat this is the classical picture no
question then the question is
how about wrong yeah
and uh i was joking with bird like a
couple of days ago that
this could place ago by the wrong paper
from
jfn 2003 is a
very important paper but this of all is
the burning thing is often
overlooked it's an important paper
because
it shows numerically therefore
non-homogeneous flow
so pod basis you pretty much
have the same type of energy cascade
mechanism as
in the fourier setting
so this gives confidence that using
functional models already viscosity type
in a reduced order modeling setting
is a valid you know
legit approach right legitimate approach
right okay
makes sense right okay and this is what
uh people
did that's how they started once again
now me
and we did the same thing and i will
talk about these models next but
here's a slide that should i hesitated
before
putting this uh slide together so yes i
mean what i've showed you so far is that
this eddy viscosity roms makes sense
make a lot of sense that's a good idea
but i don't want to get carried away
because one might think okay
so if the closure model should dissipate
energy
that means that you basically stabilize
the system so if i can stabilize the rom
in any different way then i'm done
and i want to argue that this is not the
correct approach i know this is arguable
bear with me so in fact if you study
incompressible flows like we are
with any type of alerting method this is
a question i got uh
from noel washington from carnegie
mellon a while a few years ago yeah
so for any galerkin method you you're
using finite elements or or register the
models
you can actually prove that you get
automatic stability
yeah so you multiply the weak
formulation so you use
the test function and use use uh ur
instead of the test function so use that
so that the approximation can make an
approximation
the non-linear term should uh neither
produce
nor create create nor dissipate energy
right
it's the nominee exclusive metric
nonlinear term so really
what you end up with proof you find
proof
yeah this is a proof yeah you end up
with a bound
in terms of data of your converting
solution
so what this says is that in precise
arithmetic which is not the case but
yeah you can prove that your solution is
bounded
with the galerkin method for
incompressible flows
so the problem is not only stability of
course you should get stable solution
but it's not enough they have to be
accurate
because if you use like a rom of
dimension two or three
in principle you should get a bounded
solution and i'll show you some examples
here
but that doesn't mean that it's accurate
so stability
is necessary but is not sufficient
is a subtle point that is many times
overlooked
okay nevertheless so let me get to the
results i want to present some results
now
okay um so this is a paper and all paper
that's how we started really so we
looked at the three-dimensional flow
past the ceiling there
green's number equals 1000 this is the
cylinder
and we tried classical alias models of
eddy viscosity type
we call this ev that he discussed it
iran's okay
functional models first type of first
choice obviously
and here's here are the results
so this one here you know so in blue
we have the dns so the full order model
that's the benchmark
this is an energy spectra for five
different type of models
the first one pod is just the lurking
rom
no closure ml stands for mixing length
and we have small gorinsky eddie discus
at the variation multiscale
and the dynamic stabilistic model and i
would like you to pay attention to
what's going on here so
this one the galactic rom is inaccurate
look at this
boom yeah yeah
but it doesn't blow i mean you don't
have something like a tremendous
doesn't blow up in the numerical
simulations right so it's not that it's
not stable it is
this stays stable but it's just very
inaccurate
you have too much energy in the system
the mixing length on the other hand is
too dissipative
so you see you like pushes down the the
the spectrum right below the dns value
this microsd model is better but it
still has this type of
uh variation here and as expected
from elias experience in our rom
simulations the best solutions were with
the dynamic model
and the advice positive variation
multi-skill model
so just like in lds functional models
do indeed work
they improve on standard you know like
horse type of
closures and also on the plain vanilla
uh galerkin
as expected okay now so
let's see a different type of model that
we tried later on
was of structural type and this is an
idea that has been used in
lds and we're the first i think to
extend
i believe to extend to reduce order
modeling this is an
idea stemming not from cfd
but from image processing so this is
called uh
decomposition approximately convolution
the idea is very simple
you have an approximation of the filter
variables
and you need to find the deconvolved
the filter variables because you need
this in the closure term
yeah the first thing to try with an
irritable filter
is to try the exactly convolution and we
did that and this is a stupid very bad
idea
you take any textbook and image
processing is gonna tell you the same
thing
and why is that because it's still
conditioned you'll you'll be imposed
right you know you have like a noise
that the highway numbers this is going
to be amplified when you deconvolve
very bad solutions this is textbook
material in image processing
okay so what is the solution in cfd the
solution
advocated by stalls and atoms two
decades ago we know yes
is to use some sort of approximate
deconvolution
just like in image processing different
people use different things we use the
simplest one
which is the variety of regularization
and we use this in our alias rom
framework
no eddie viscosity per se no id
viscosity
this is our model first we didn't use a
projection
we use a spatial filter the differential
filter
we solved a low dimensional helmholtz
equation
and this is our model you can see here
that wr
wr represents the approximation of the
filtered variables
and wrad takes wr the filter variable
and computes the approximately
convolution of it that's what we use
in here in the non-linear term i also
want to emphasize
to to note a nice trick that we use
really
here we should have a bar so we should
filter the nonlinear term at each time
step
what this is the differential filter
itself a joint
we move the filter to the test function
so we work i
haven't seen this before so i'm excited
right so we work with
field third test functions you cannot do
this in finite element because you have
a million test functions how do you
filter them
but when you do start the model and you
filter them and you store them no
problem
it worked this is this is a wall network
okay
published this uh four years ago okay
now
finally the last thing that i want to
talk about and we'll
i think i'm gonna go five minutes over
the time limit sorry about that
is a data data-driven approach so this
is something that
is not that was you know was not used
decades ago in lds but
it's it's starting to be used now and
definitely in the use of the modeling
community this is a very hot area and i
think a
perfect fit for for alias drum enclosure
uh reduce order model okay as our
framework we use the variation
multiscale that is to say
a spatial filter use the projection it's
very natural
and i used huge's idea from the 2000 two
decades ago
because i think it's simple general and
powerful
it works like it feels like a glove to
our
hierarchical structure that we use in
the distorted modeling
and other people believe the same thing
yeah um
so basically this is the simple idea we
divide the scales into result scales
that's what we're using
and our is all scales that's those are
the scales that we discard
and use this two-scale decomposition
right so
resolved large-scale modes and our
result modes
it's very similar to lds you can do
you can divide the result most into two
scales like results large results first
and small result scale so that's a three
scale
variation notice but i'm gonna just
present the derivation for the two scale
because it's simple
the other the physical one is similar
okay so how do we do this this is the
algorithm
it's very simple so basically we take
the
entire connect collection of raw modes
so the snapshots
you can think even like you know like
experimental data doesn't so everything
all the information you have
from this information you you only keep
the first
most important modes like we don't
reduce toward the model
okay and then look what we do
we use the form data available form data
and we calculate we calculate the
real true closure model
for the with the font data
then we solve this least squares problem
to find the entries in our
matrix a tilde a matrix b tilde
that model the nonlinear closure term
so basically this is a hybrid approach
we use the galactic rom a dot is equal
to matrix a times a plus a transpose
tensor b
times a but then we add some some
corrections
a matrix a tilde and the tensor b tilde
and of course we can use like a third
you know uh
cubic tensor cpu that we tried that
and yeah so you can use anything you
want but but
these are correction terms closure terms
that come from data a tilde and btu.com
from data
that's the closure model for us but
a and b are the standard golorchin
operators so this is a hybrid approach
in which data driven modeling this d
squares problem
is used to to come up with a model for
the closure term
we've used fat of course you can i mean
we just need squares because
that's what that's what we that's what
it started with but you can use you know
we can use machine learning you can use
all sorts of ideas data-driven modeling
any type of
metadata modeling yeah okay now
does it work so we started very simple
with the
simplest test case two-dimensional the
workforce
two-dimensional flow past the cylinder
everyone loves this one
and it worked in fact here i'm
displaying an example where the three
scale
model does better result does better
than the two scale one
but overall both two scale and three
scale they're actually
uh good ones they work pretty well okay
two dimensional range number equals to
one thousand okay
then we said okay can we improve these
models if we want to work
go to harder problems can we improve
these mods and here's
what i think is an important ingredient
uh
physical constraints for the lurking
drum
the situation is very clear your matrix
a
it is dissipating right because it comes
from the
diffusion operator so you should
dissipate energy clearly
the non-linear operator is conservative
okay it has to satisfy if you use excuse
symmetra's formulation right so it has
to satisfy it's incompressible
yeah and the non-linear term should not
create or
dissipate energy should just move it
around the scales
that's the that's the idea you can prove
that right okay
how about the closure model well the
collision model is not that clear right
so what you would like
is to have the closure model be
dissipative
on the average so in the meaning
that's based on the paper that i've
shown you the backward facing staff of
complex
okay right now we didn't quite know how
to enforce this because here this is a
tensor this was a matrix so if we said
okay
let's do this let's impose that a tilde
b
dissipative just like a to be similar in
spirit
and then b till they'll be conservative
just like
this one there's really no api reason to
say that
it's just that if we do this then this
one is satisfied
so this is obviously sufficient
sufficient
condition but it's not necessary
that's what we use though yeah okay um
okay well is this really important so
for the simple problem
again two flow past the circular
cylinder with
fewer modes r equals three so we try to
push down
r to break it down it turns out that
using this constraint formulation
with the physical constraints helps
okay all right and then we said
we got again confidence we said let's
work with harder problems
this is the uh so we looked at quasi
geostrophic equations that are modern in
the large-scale
ocean circulation if you look at the
north atlantic
you see the gyres here and here
and this is the gulf stream that goes on
the coast
you know eastern coast and then then
veers to the right goes all the way here
warms up the
north the northern european side can we
simulate this
with the use of the models and here are
the results
so it turns out that for the
type of problem that we've used if you
average
the stream function over the time
you get a four gyr pattern this is a
paper published by
uh great badge in navigable uh 20 years
ago yeah
geoscientists right however if you use a
galerkin rom
then you get two giants
so completely wrong type of uh average
it turns out that with our closure model
you do recover the four giants
in both cases constrained so with
physical constraints
and without the physical constraints but
this constrained version is more
accurate than the unconstrained one
so both of them are correct
qualitatively but you get an improvement
in accuracy improvement if you use the
physical constraints
okay so um i know that my time is up
very soon i want to end up with a
test run that i told you about this is
part of chiang hong's phd thesis is
defending uh next friday this is
the 3d turbulent channel flow much much
much harder problem for use for the
modeling
i have to tell you up front that our
model our closure model by itself
does not work so you see full disclosure
i'm honest all right um
the rain was numbered reynolds
established 395. 395 that corresponds to
balgrinos number 1300 750. it's a lot of
motion
in here it's difficult it's a difficult
test problem
and this has been pointed out before
okay
so here are the results the results in a
nutshell are very simple so
again if you just use the closure the
data driven closure model by itself
we don't get very good results
okay so this would be uh so this these
are the mean uh
the first order statistics this is i
mean uh
um statistics and this would be the uh
one two component of the real stress
tensor second order statistics
okay and in um in
purple so we have this the solid line
with a solid line we have the truth
and the rest are just our less type of
less rom
so that ddms rom simulations
okay of different types the dd dms rom
without anything
gives bad results the best results we've
obtained
i would say not surprisingly
were with the hybrid formulation in
which to the data-driven closure model
we added some eddy viscosity
component we try so
if you just turn off the advice cause it
is only data driven model
you don't get good results if you turn
out the date turn off the data driven
component and just use the edit
dispositive um you still don't get this
good results it turns out that for us
the best results were
obtained with putting them together and
choosing
the right combination trial and error
okay this is i'm saying unsurprisingly
because this is pretty much what happens
in lds as well
um i can talk more about this but uh
this is this this is uh
what we expected pretty much this type
of simulations in
turbulent channel flow yeah okay
so this is really what i had to say i
want to
uh to summarize and to uh have a few uh
you know point out a few thoughts but
before i do i so i have one slide
because i promise this about some math
and we're very proud
that we've recently been able to prove
that
if our closure model is accurate
we can prove that our approximation is
accurate as well
this is on the right hand side we have
the the rom closure error
so the air between the true form
closure model and the real practical rom
closure model e is the error
between the
closure model approximation you are
and the filter variable so we know what
we're approximating
many times people don't i would say okay
so why is that using alerting plus
filtering that gives us a mathematical
for our formulation
and the fact that we are in our data
driven model
we are approximating the closure model
this
helps us to bound the right hand side
okay final thoughts
i hope that you remember and you i don't
the take-home message would be that
even in rom just like in les you do
encounter
under-dissolved drums when you work with
top problems like the turbulent channel
flow
or like real turbulence turbulent
channel flow is an academic test problem
come on
yeah the spatial filter is an important
component this is not very well
discussed
many times it's swept under the rug uh i
believe that this is what
makes possible connecting less and
disorder modeling
data is something that was you know is
not mainstreaming
in lds and physical constraints that's
something that
does help i think if you know something
about the physics you should use
okay elias ram is a simple powerful
technique
and it's mathematical we can prove
theorems about it
i like that okay i'm a mathematician so
okay and i will end up with uh some um
some of our papers i would be happy if
you
um you know contacted me and asked me
about uh
some of our work i'll try to be i'm
selling stuff
obviously but i will try to be honest
and uh and answer your questions
uh clearly eddie viscosity functional
models were at the beginning of our work
with
our focus then structure models lately
data driven modeling i think there is a
lot of potential here and we already
scratched the surface
um and i will end here and wait for your
questions thank you thank thank you so
much that was a wonderful talk
thank you thank you uh we do have a
question from the chat room
let's go over from the first one um
the first question is coming from
maxwell
he asked dd offline simulation involve
use of sgs
model okay maxwell so this is this is a
good question i'm not sure
uh right i'm not sure
uh thanks now thank you so uh thank you
so i'm not sure what you mean by offline
simulation so if you mean
generating the data then uh
yes for the turbulent channel you're
okay that's a good point
to generate data for the turbulent
channel flow
we did use lds yes that is correct
um and uh so we did use an alias model
and
we compared our results so this is well
done in
my my collaborators group called the red
holes
um and he compared his results with the
standard
um
mojo kim mansour data set for
the turbulent channel flow and he got
reasonable um
uh you know match so declare success i
think that lds people do this a lot if
you if your lds model
matches the data set then you know that
what you're doing is
right so my my question actually was i
was trying to find out
uh what type of uh subgrid scheme order
that was used
was this margaronsky structure function
model
i would have to go back and then look
this up but it was not this mag risky
model it was not an
uh maybe viscosity model it was a model
that involved
um approximately convolution if i'm not
mistaken but i would have to go back to
the paper and check that i can get back
to you if you want
okay thank you you're very welcome
that's a very good question and this is
okay so i want to to emphasize another
point i know that
john luigi rosa's group is also adamant
about this
i think there's a lot of value in
actually working with data
that comes from realistic settings of
course you can generate dns from data
for simple problems
but for realistic turbulent flows you're
going to have to use
something else like lds like rans
something like that so data is not going
to be perfect
and i think there is value in trying to
in working with that data that is not
perfect
and do the best what you know the best
you can do it you reduce toward the
model
i don't think that we should assume
always assume that data is perfect
it's not perfect our data was not but
it's realistic that's what you do in
practice
that's what you can work with
okay thank you the second question are
coming
again from maxwell what is the
computational efficiency of the rom
okay this is a very good point so um
this is this channel flow i'm not so
sure so
this work in progress is going to be in
chiang hong's uh
uh but i can tell you about the first
the this magorinsky type of uh
dynamic subject scale uh eddie viscosity
rom
that i've shown you the the one from
2012.
so the speed up factor was on the order
of you know so it
uh it was on the other 1000
so we used six modes so it was
it was flow past the circular ceiling
there that's a good problem 3d flow past
the circular cylinder
the speed up factor was significant yeah
so so orders of magnitude significant
now for the turbulent channel flow
this is something that i have not
emphasized we used
r is equal to 10 so we use 10 modes
really you should take on the order of
100 modes to do something
to to work well with the galerkin round
but we used on the order
we used r is equal to 10. so the online
simulation
is very cheap the offline so generation
of data assembling the operators is
is you know expensive but the online one
because of this very small dimension 10
r is equal to ten
not a hundred ten so this was
um so they were pretty efficient
okay the next question is from yulia
uh he asked the limitation of les
is that it assumes that energy
production and dissipation of the small
scales are in
equilibrium how roms work if they are
not
in equilibrium okay so you guys are so
she asked a very good question and um
okay so
maybe i was a little bit cavalier about
the whole thing so
i want to emphasize that that
that rom alias drums are nowhere
close to the level of mathematics
and and you know like support
mathematical support
that lds is okay so
so i really cannot we only have
qualitative data uh numerical data
we can make qualitative type of
statements i don't think there is
anything
close to the you know like the type of
universal
uh scaling laws that you have for uh for
turbo for les for turbulence in general
yeah we do not know what happens in a
rom setting
the main reason i believe is the fact
that
the run basis the rom space is not
unique
so you have one type of ram space for
the flow passes cylinder we have a
different type of ramp space for
cavity flow and you know so on and so
forth
this is problem dependent it's hard to
come up with some sort of mathematical
type of
framework that is general i think it
would be nice
and this is one of my things like data i
didn't call my gorop
for for for for wrong yeah but with
i haven't seen anything close to that so
i cannot answer your question
yeah we don't right now to my knowledge
we don't have anything
that is anywhere close to what lds
people have
so i don't know yeah i mean i'm not even
astute this these are all assumptions
that we're making based on some scales
numerical evidence
we plug things in we try them and if
they work we declare success
that's what we're doing right now so
you're right i mean you it's a critical
comment and what is correct
you're right okay next question
from eek can you get the
log layer velocity profile in a channel
correctly with rom
oh i see so you're asking about what
happens near the
near the wall um
okay i mean so if you so i don't know
the
honest answer is i don't know we haven't
looked into this uh carefully
but i believe that i mean it's like
always like with data given much this is
the runs are data driven models
so if your data
lies runs i don't know whatever right so
dns if that data captures it well
and if the galerkin rom
uses enough basis functions
100 could be a thousand depending on
renal style right
so then i believe that yes you would be
able i don't know i believe that the
answer would be yes
if however instead of a hundred modes
you stand like we did or five
you might miss that and of course if the
data itself with the snapshots do not
capture that
the rom itself is not gonna magically
uh uh you know put put that back in
so so yeah yeah i mean we haven't tried
that but i believe that it all depends
on how much
data you're using in your model if you
use enough data then i believe that you
can replicate the form yes
near the wall even near the law okay
i don't know okay the the last question
we see is oh oh we got one more
okay the second last question from john
uh great talk by the way
what is your opinion of uh color can
wrong with the pressure
super miser okay this is a great
question
i said uh this is a very good a very
good question
um so i so my focus was on closure
so you know closure modeling and so on
but
there is a yeah you know
there's a good question about what you
do about pressure
in our group the approach that we've
taken has been
uh pragmatic
i think when you talk about supervisors
this is the type of work that john luigi
rosa and his group
francesco balamin and others have
developed
it is mathematically correct perfect
and and i don't know if i cannot see the
all the participants but
if anyone is here they can correct me so
but if you read that 2015
ijnmf paper they will say that
yes if you use the supervisors you can
get
good pressure approximations but
it's quite expensive computationally
so they have a second subsection in
which they show that
actually using an approximation of those
supervisors
a more practical approach may be
non-mathematically perfect
so satisfying the instant condition you
still get
a good approximation of your pressure
and i think that this is the point
automatically you should satisfy the
insulin condition
most of the time right yeah but that can
be expensive
so the approach we take in our group is
that we violate the instant condition so
we do not have supervisors
but use stabilization methods so we
admit that we violate the input
condition
we admit that we have pressure
oscillations
and then we use some
pressure stabilization algorithms to
take care of the oscillations in the
pressure
this is not mathematically as elegant as
the supremizer approach
but it works in practice so it's dirty
but
practical i hope that this answer your
question but
so but if you have if it doesn't please
let me know and i'll
i'll be glad to elaborate on that
okay the the thank you teren um
the last question from the chat room i
see is from
vision um in the navy stop scaling rom
why do you multiply a transpose only
with the non-linear term and
not the linear term okay this is uh
this is you know i ask myself the same
question so this is a notation this is
notation so it's not that we multiply
this
and this you know you have also to i
have to explain what i mean by
vector a transpose b
vector a what does that mean
thanks alessandra so what does that mean
what it means
component wise this is a double sum
over a sub m a sub
n and then you have the nonlinear term
so this is just notation if you can
think about the finite element
procedure it's the same thing is just
notation for
computing the finite element
approximation of the non-linear term
it's not that i multiply that i do like
in the vector matrix type of
multiplications
b is a tensor so you have to multiply by
a vector twice in order to get a vector
pretty much that's the idea it's just
notation it's not
nothing like um test functions or
anything like that
very good very good um i
great yeah let's thank the our speaker
um
treyan for the wonderful job a wonderful
talk and wonderful
answers to to all the questions he
being asked um i don't know i i don't
see any
any other question from the chat room
but
we would like to open to any audiences
if you willing to unmute yourself and
ask your ask the questions please go
go ahead i mean yeah i mean i know we we
have over
you know the pastor over time um
sorry that's that's fine i mean the
people who
who has a meeting um already left and
um i assume the the people here are
available
and listen to more um
if they you know and so yeah
sorry so young so also if you feel uh
that you know you don't feel comfortable
asking these questions and the
being recorded or whatnot so you can
drop me an email
i would be very happy to to to try to
answer
uh this type of questions uh whether
they're technical
or as much as said
philosophical as you can see i like to
philosophize and
but anyway so if you say if you send me
an email i would be very happy to to
to try to answer your questions yeah so
you can do this uh
afterwards yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah
the the so the sorting out some
the big picture with the philosophical
question is very important so
don't hesitate to ask those
philosophical questions to
try on um all right
that sounds like i have one question oh
wonderful
okay so like uh in
the slide number 27. okay so i can
try to go there just give me one second
so let's see
i want to go to 27. i guess i could go
faster
using the panel okay yes
uh so you said that these are energy
plots
yes they are so these are energy
spectrum
uh they are for what application right
so these are for the 3d
flow past the circular cylinder this is
the one in white here
a flow comes from the left to the right
and the rails number is
1000 we used a finite volume
so this is work of imran so he was a
postdoc
uh working at virginia tech so so
he used a finite volume discretization
with i want to say half a million
degrees of freedom maybe
800k um it is so he compared we compared
the
um left and right coefficients and
through her numbers with the published
data
so this was the form then we took the
full order model
then we took that data and we generated
the
pod aces
and we used six modes for this numerical
for
all the numerical simulations no closure
model here
closure models in these four mixing
lengths magarinsky
eddie viscosity dms and the dynamic
sub-scale model
and one thing i didn't say is that
for the mixing length we optimize the
coefficients
on the interval time interval 075
but then we ran the rom the closure
model on the interval 0 to 300 so 4
times
so this is predictive in in a sense
right so
we we calibrated the coefficients but
then we use the rom
on a longer tiny interval
uh so up to what range is
uh the period galactan usable
that's a good question that's a good
very good question so
um i mean we so you mean in terms of
reynolds number or in terms of like uh
dimension or both yeah but
okay okay this is a good question so
excuse me so to be honest
so the answer is i don't know right
but um i think that if you ask me right
now
based on my experience what type of
models are you i will use
i would use for a high rails number
uh simulation i would say in some form
i would use some at least some of these
advs capacity models
they are the workhorse of lds
they're not very beautiful
mathematically but they're the workhorse
you can find them in actual
you know like uh commercial software
yeah they're default right there is a
reason for that they do work
in fact i believe that our model does
not do them justice
because it's a very low rents number one
thousand
i think it would be interesting to try
them in high rails number terminal flow
simulations
okay i think that they could work so i
would pick them for example
yeah i haven't done that we haven't done
that but
but i would look into that now in terms
of breaking down the
rom by by shrinking the basis functions
the number of uh basis functions so it
so we use six i mean so it's pretty low
dimensional right
um i don't remember if we tried the
lower values but i would assume that if
you
go down like to three or four uh you get
uh
bad results but i can show you something
so let me just show you something really
quickly uh
yeah really quickly so well okay for our
two dimensional
uh flow simulations so
we started with four and it worked fine
our model our data given model but then
when we
moved down to three so we decreased the
size
it didn't work out so well so then we
have to use
you know like these guys so these
physical constraints and
the roms the the lurking rom
as you push down the number of basis
functions is gonna break down
at some point it's hard for me to tell
you what exactly what what
that point is but uh it will break down
okay okay wow
just one last question sure uh so
uh why use peoria and why not uh any uh
any other
disorder models thank you thank you so
this is vishan
is that is that your name i'm sorry i
cannot say it was okay
okay so this is a great question and i
should have said that
we do use pod but we did use other
basis functions okay so
so actually we're looking at using you
know looking at dmd
how this would adapt all i said
everything i said i believe the the
philosophy the
the the principles it applies equally
well
to other basis functions is nothing that
is related this
is is is stuck on pod we have not done
this
other than you know two three types of
examples but
you can try anything else there's
nowhere
that we use the specific pod flavor
of our bases this is a general type of
framework
uh okay yeah thank you
you're very welcome good question i i
have a following comments on that you
know the
it's all boils down to how
you can how well you can represent your
your solution
um whether it is turbulence or whatever
the physical simulations you are
involved with
right and pod is happens to be one of
them
and you know any types of other solution
representing reduce the solution
representation
if we can capture important dynamics
of the physics that's applicable in the
context of
student model you know the
non-linear manifold solution
representation is
is getting a lot of attention and
it will be really interesting to see you
know applying that into turbulence
i completely agree you know and as you
as you know so ma'am i would like to
to to to work with you on some of that
because
i this was done on purpose i really
didn't even
show you a slide on pod and that's why i
guess vishanti is asking the question
because i really believe that this is
a um the principles apply as you said
if you have a wrong basis that
represents well the
the dynamics of the of the system then
this this type of approach would be
could could be applied as well
of course if you have enough modes
whether they are from you know from
machine learning not
in your manifolds or like silly but
so basic pod doesn't matter right
but if you already can do well with your
lurking rom there's no need for closure
however
if you push your galerkin wrong to the
range of high realms number you know
turbulent
flow type of simulations at some point
i claim i conjecture that even the best
way
of representing your data if it's not in
your manifold or something else
it's going to break down at some point
it's going to break down because
you just simply don't cannot represent
the entire dynamics
that's when lds type of ideas can come
to your rescue okay
but if you have enough modes to
represent the dynamics
you don't need any closure model and
that's why people like this 2d flow
faster cylinder because with
four more or six modes i forgot right
you can represent everything
right but if you don't try channel flow
for the people who say
we can do this and that try channel flow
if you can do it then you have
a good tool but i claim that at some
point you increase the renal style
number
it's gonna break down and that's when
lds is gonna be helpful
i think all right sounds good okay
um the one last question from the chat
room
uh by her uh he asked
can you comment on the predictive
capability of ddvms wrong
this is a great question i was waiting
for this so the some of the results i
presented were for the predictive regime
uh hashid you know i didn't i didn't
talk too much about this but they were
for the predictability
of course if you do your
training on a small window and then you
let things run
you know and you change parameters and
things like that it's gonna break down
but this is a problem with um i think
with data driven modeling in
in general so we're training
our closure model on some available data
if the closure model that we get is
representative
for a larger set and this in our
experience
it was then we do use it successfully in
a predictive
regime but you can ask the following
question
so let's say that you get eight tilde
and b time
for reynolds number equals let's say
ten thousand in our experience
we can use the same type of a tilde m b
tilde
for you know reynolds numbers close to
ten thousand let's say i don't know
fifty thousand maybe even twenty
thousand
but what if you want to simulate
adrenals number equals one million
are you gonna still have the same ethic
and be to that and the answer
is probably not and our numericals
you know experiments show that no that's
not the question so
if you increase the lens number by a
factor of 10 100
you're not gonna have you cannot use the
same eight to that
this is related to the question
asked by the previous speaker at the
beginning i think her name was julia
yeah banarska ram
is different from kolmogorov statistical
theory
we don't have that that theory
is valid over all the real examples we
don't have that in rome
so our models should not be expected to
be valid of a range of
reynolds numbers and so on and so forth
at best
we can have in my opinion we can have
this type of scaling laws for
fixed examples slow past the cylinder
then a different type of saving law for
cavity flow then a different type of
you know scaling law for like flow past
here
maybe follows you know a narrower range
of reyes numbers
so that i believe it's so it have an
atlas an atlas
of scaling loss for different test
problems maybe
but have something like julia was asking
like for
all the range of parameters i don't
think that that's gonna
be true okay
thank you so much okay well
it's uh we spent like 90 minutes
no no no don't be sorry it's good it's
good
it's it's impossible to um you know
convey you know all the all the
knowledge you have
accumulated through the decades of the
uh the research of the experience on on
turbulence
reduced to the modeling in 90 minutes or
60 minutes so it's impossible so
so please um i i would like to encourage
all of you
uh if you have further discussion uh
please contact um
uh professor tyrian um he's
very responsive respond responsive uh
based on my experience
all right let's thank uh professor
taryan again thank you
thank you big applause thank you guys
thank you great questions thank you
thank you young soo i and thank you so
much
all of you uh remain stay here like for
the full 90 minutes uh the seminar
thank you yeah all right um i guess we
can
um wrap it up here